[Música]
abrimos la revista de prensa este día
martes con rosa pérez más de eeuu por
supuesto rosa vamos a empezar entonces
con una investigación del new york
times' por el asesinato de la periodista
del medio al yazira chiringa bucle
buenos días raúl exactamente recordemos
bueno las circunstancias en que siguió
ese asesinato fue el 11 de mayo cuando
como bien decías la periodista de al
yazira el shooting agua que junto con un
grupo de compañeros periodistas cubría
una redada del ejército de israel a un
campo de refugiados palestinos en jenín
cisjordania bueno en ese momento en esas
circunstancias pues si un agua que fue
alcanzada por una bala que distintas
organizaciones en distintas
investigaciones independientes por
partes de medios de comunicación han
atribuido a las fuerzas de israel sin
embargo pues 40 días después de su
asesinato éste todavía no ha sido pues
reconocido por nadie la autoría todavía
pues no ha sido reconocida sin embargo
pues el new york times se suma ahora
lista de medios que hacen una
investigación independiente sobre las
circunstancias de esta matanza
recordemos que new york times' en un
primer momento fue criticado porque
cuando se conoció la muerte de la
periodista el new york times título
sidina bucle muere a los 51 años no un
muere pues a digamos no es exacto
entonces ahora sí que new york times
publica el asesinato de chilina bubble
trazando una bala hasta un convoy
israelí y bien como hizo anteriormente
evelyn cut a société presión en el
washington post pues cruzan imágenes
satélites con imágenes publicadas en
redes sociales
en ese mismo día con testigos para
establecer que efectivamente esa bala
pues provenía de una zona fue disparada
desde el lugar donde había un convoy
israelí y fue probablemente disparada
por un soldado de una unidad de élite
sin embargo dice el new york times' que
no puede establecer que quien disparó
viera que giren y sus colegas llevaban
chalecos identificados como prensa sin
embargo hay que matizar esto porque los
testigos en el primer momento dijeron
que ellos cuando se dirigían a la zona
se mostraron
pues los soldados israelís para que los
identificaran como prensa y por otro
lado en las distintas investigaciones de
los otros medios de comunicación hemos
leído como distintos expertos señalan
que la oreja donde fue disparada es
irina bucle que es una zona donde suelen
disparar los soldados pues a la prensa
porque es una zona que queda
desprotegida por el casco bien así sea
como sea pues se trae el new york times
como los otros medios de comunicación
señalan que todo apunta pues a que esto
la bala fue disparada eso sí por un
soldado israelí recordemos como ya dijo
bening cate a société presas tienen el
washington post y también precisamente
si lo señale la agencia palestina de
noticias rosa la guapa exactamente que
dice pues investigaciones de grandes
medios de eeuu confirman lo que los
palestinos han estado diciendo todo este
tiempo y es que pues no había palestinos
armados pues en la zona y esto significa
que la bala pues no pudo provenir de
pues un arma disparada por un palestino
y que difícilmente también pues un
soldado israelí pudo disparar a siuna
booklet confundiéndola con un soldado
palestino y precisamente él la jerusalem
post' también este medio israelí urge
también a las autoridades de israel que
hagan públicos sus hallazgos en las
investigaciones tanto del asesinato de
sirena booklet como de la actuación
policial recordemos el día del funeral
en que todo el mundo bien vio esas
imágenes de la policía cargando contra
las personas que cargaban el ataúd que
casi pues se cae al sol a cambiamos de
información rosa famosa francia porque
el editorial de limón comenta el
resultado de las elecciones en colombia
exactamente el mont dice la izquierda
ante el desafío del poder en américa
latina y pues como subtítulo dice en
colombia pero también en perú chile
argentina la fuerza de la izquierda en
américa central y del sur es general el
espantapájaros el fantasma que ha
constituido durante mucho tiempo
venezuela contra modelo de devastación
social ya no da miedo bien centrándose
en colombia dice que la victoria de
gustavo petro y francia- márquez supone
recuerda la primera vez que la izquierda
llega al poder en el país dice que es
destacable y hay que felicitarla
la moderna como la madurez política de
colombia teniendo en cuenta que es un
país marcado por la violencia y que aún
así las elecciones han transcurrido sin
mayores altercados que la oposición ha
reconocido el resultado electoral y que
ha habido una amplia participación
también dice hay que reconocer la
voluntad del presidente electo gustavo
petro y su vicepresidenta electa francia
márquez pues de poner la lucha contra el
cambio climático en el centro de sus
políticas y dice que esta llegada de la
izquierda al poder en colombia responde
por un lado a un distanciamiento de la
sociedad respecto al catolicismo
conservador imperante en la región como
demuestran dice las leyes pues por los
derechos del aborto en méxico argentina
o colombia donde dice hay que destacar
también que el país es pionero en las
leyes que protegen el suicidio asistido
como también pues dice esta izquierda
esta llegada de la izquierda al poder
responde por un crecimiento de las
desigualdades pues provocado por décadas
de políticas neo liberales que han hecho
pues que la gente ya no tenga miedo
digamos a este como decía el titular
espantapájaros no de venezuela movido
por la derecha del continente y que
finalmente pues las izquierdas que están
llegando al poder en américa latina no
son tampoco pues demasiado radicales
sino más bien lo que se consideraría en
muchos lugares como social de motos y es
rosa vamos a ver este tema precisamente
con el superior imitado el día pero
rápido cerramos entonces con el nuevo
llega si está si el tenemos novedades de
este medio pero lamentablemente no es
que vuelva a publicar recordemos que
este medio independiente ruso cesó sus
publicaciones en marzo debido a la
censura en rusia sobre las informaciones
relacionadas con la guerra en ucrania
sin embargo su director dmitri murátov
vendió su medalla de oro del premio
nobel que ganó en 2021 por 103 ciento
3,5 millones de dólares y donó este
dinero pues a unicef para que lo
transmita a los niños desplazados por la
guerra en ucrania rosa muchísimas
gracias entonces por esta revista de
prensa hoy martes mañana miércoles con
massa revista de prensa por supuesto
salud nuestro primer invitado el día